I'm not confident that a 18 year old now
today could make actually a coherent
argument against racism because they
never have to dip never heard one right
it's just ban ban ban and that you know
that it that is what is making us it's
gonna make us stupid in the long term
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts are
brilliant guests this week is a staff
writer at spiked online and the host of
the spiked podcast phrase - welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me it's
good to have you here we've been meaning
to get you on for a while and we're glad
that you're here for anyone who doesn't
know you just tell us very quickly who
are you what's your background how are
you where you are um so I write for
spikes which i think is the best
magazine in the world probably the only
magazine standing up today for you know
absolute free speech democracy no ifs no
buts and for you know a very humanist
Pro human centered outlet have you read
The Guardian yeah we've had a few
run-ins with them you know and I guess I
mean you you know it's it's I have kind
of a funny journey I guess I mean I'm a
massive massive prexy supporter so might
as well get that out now well when you
said democracy knows nobody I think
every you don't you hope so but I guess
I'm not a typical well I didn't have the
typical journey into being a brick city
you know I speak two foreign languages I
speak French and German I studied them
at university and it was funny because
it was actually while I was on my year
abroad doing the Erasmus thing that it's
supposed to turn me into the you know
perfect EU citizen remainer type that
was also the year where things
were you know really hitting the fan in
Europe and that was when you know
certain doubts about this wonderful
European Union started to creep in yeah
and it was really it was really funny
because it's actually a lot of Lawrence
while I was in Germany and nothing bad
was really happening there yeah
but lots of bad things were happening in
Greece you could see that you know the
if the you know not only had a
referendum been ignored over the over
the proposed bailouts but there was
going to be austerity for the next 70
years proposed by the European Union so
you know these so these kind of things
like oh maybe this isn't this isn't what
I thought it is you know I always been a
sort of maybe back then as a bit wet but
you know I've always been a kind of
lefty type and I could start to see that
that was not really fitting in with you
know my ideals and then we kind of get
fast forward to 2016 didn't think about
it that much and then we suddenly we
have this referendum on the EU question
and it just suddenly becomes really
obvious you know what what am I going to
vote for well I'm gonna vote to leave
because what else would you do you know
where I live with my friends you know
from Paul well-educated living in London
you stick out a bit like a sore thumb
but you know all pro remain even if they
kind of understood my arguments they'd
say oh and you know you're different you
you're a different argument
that's not why other people are going
leave but actually if you talk to people
across the country who vote for a brexit
the same things keep coming up and and
the main things are you know democracy
and sovereignty a few people are
interested in immigration but actually
that's bound up in the democracy
question because that's something that
has been taken off the table for so long
in this country you know you cannot have
an open debate about immigration and
even if you did you can't change the
policy anyway so what would be the point
that makes a lot of sense yeah and we
started with break so we want to we want
to stay away from that as much as we can
so but there is something that there
it's part of a bigger thing yeah and one
of the things about you speak in French
and German is you've done a lot of great
reporting on the julies on the yellow
vests in France
and we really wanted to talk to you at
length about that so for anyone who just
watched the other BBC news one time a
couple of months ago and saw some French
people don't want to work again is it
just that or is it more - I think you
know it obviously it's part of a wider
European populist revolt and and you
know the BRICS is is one part of that
there's things going on in Italy things
even in countries like Sweden where we
don't even expect there to be pop twist
revolts I mean this is the French
reaction this is their version of it I
suppose it's it is extraordinary I mean
it's not just a handful of people
turning up protesting this has been
going on at the time recording for 26
weeks every weekend people have gone out
in you know whatever the weather is
including the winter it started in
November and stood there and tried to
make themselves visible that's one of
the exciting things about the Sheila
Johnson is that you cannot ignore these
people anymore
they're there they're these are people
who have been ignored in politics for a
very long time they don't live in the
cities so they're not you know connected
into either the global economy or you
know or democratic politics they live in
the kind of peripheries there as I often
say you know just because they're there
because they're peripheral to the cities
that means they've also become
peripheral to politics in many ways
they're not listened to they have living
standards either stagnating or in
decline and nobody cares or nobody cared
until they started to make their voices
heard and now this is gonna sound
flippant but there's a more serious
point behind this the French have always
liked kicking off yeah they always have
they've always they've always liked a
bit of a row they've always loved to
strike you know this episode of the
[Laughter]
punch like onions and yeah I mean it's
it's a flippant comment but there's a
certain amount of truth to it and how
much is it that they do with hike you
know so you know getting upset yeah
throw strike
and how much of this is actually a
genuine working-class revolt against the
you know the upper classes well I think
you have to think about the scale of it
I mean yes you're right French people do
protest a lot more than we do for
instance you know they do go and strike
a lot more than we do and I think that's
I think good on them personally you know
why why should they put up with anything
less than than what they what they
deserve but they're scared of it I mean
this is the biggest revolt since 1968
you know since the laser Vein more as
they call them which changed French
society you know enormous Lee it changed
basically ushered in the kind of modern
era of you know how we think of France
today and and this is and this is
actually bigger potentially you know
you're talking it started off with two
hundred thousand people you had hundreds
of thousands of people after that still
tens of thousand people thousands of
people going out we can't week in week
out it's been going on for over five
months and a most extraordinary to me is
is the way that it just doesn't really
get the kind of coverage you expect you
know you mentioned the BBC earlier you
know you if this were Venezuela or
something it would be on television
every day but it's and it's only
happening across the channel it's a it's
not difficult for a journalist to go
over there like I did I spent thirty
five pounds to get on a coach to go to
Paris to go talk to people it's not hard
and but that's not really happening and
and it's quite funny because there are
these kind of rumors going around the
internet and people have asked me you
know there's a rumor in Britain that
there's a d' notice on the GAO jean that
the government has banned you know
newspapers from reporting reporting on
in people have asked me about that
completely untrue the the truth is much
sadder people are just not interested
people in our establishment are not
interested people in the French
establishment have to be interested
because they're afraid of them and
they're afraid of what might happen next
but you know it is there is a
recognition that these are the kind of
wrong kind of people these are the
famous deplorable 's you know the French
deplorable is if you like and so their
needs their interests their demands do
just sort of fall on on
phears in a way and what is it all about
is it like a French brexit where these
are people who are against the EU or is
it much more about you know as you said
that kind of people who've lost out
through globalization just wanting to
you know have a job have a house have a
secure stable future for themselves and
their children
maybe opposed to immigration just tell
us a little bit about what is their kind
of what is the core of their concerns
yeah I think it's I mean you know the EU
plays into it and the EU has has played
a role in the diminishing of their
living standards and certainly the euro
in the last you know 10 years has has
made it very difficult for you know the
French economy in the French government
to adapt to various changes and that has
a real serious problem you know there
there's seriously economic causes lots
of people are not only is there high
unemployment but people sort of know
that if they lose their job now that's
it these are people who have quite
stagnant careers they ought sorry they
don't even have careers at all they have
jobs normal careers you know there's no
advancement and a lot of them feel some
of them are you know nearing retirement
age and they have a sense that things
aren't going to be better for the next
generation and that's intolerable and we
need to do something about it and you
know in my view I don't think that the
problems of the French economy can be
fixed within the European Union there
are some people in the g-load zones who
are explicitly anti-eu there is a big
crossover as well in the people who are
protesting against the GLA Zhang's and
those who voted in 2015 in 2015 the
French were asked to ratify the European
Constitution and most of them said no
they voted against it
it was then repackaged as the lisbon
treaty and forced through onto them
anyway so and there is a crossover
between many of the people who are the G
legends who will live and who will have
voted against that European Constitution
it but things are a lot less clear-cut
because they you know it's a leaderless
movement it doesn't have an official
manifesto so it's hard to say that there
is any specific demands other than the
more general
and for greater living standards and a
greater say in in politics and there's
been criticisms from certain aspects or
from certain parts of the left who've
said that the GLA Jones is a far
right-wing anti-immigration you know
whatever Pro you know Pro fracture I
think it is movement where do you stand
on that well I think it's it's
interesting because the far-right slur
came out you know from basically from
the French government within hours of
people turning up on the streets they
these people as I said before you know
these are the the deplorable these
people don't have to open their mouths
before someone has decided that they're
far right and actually you know if you
look at the police reports there's no
significant far-right influence there's
the far left have started to get a bit
more interested in the Julien's which
you know fine and there's that there's
also been you know some attempts by the
trade union movements to do to make
links with the Giro zones but the idea
that these people are far right is is
ludicrous I mean some of them will have
voted for the National Front in the past
you know but then what other options did
they did they have you know it's it's
like many people who will vote for UK I
don't think it's because they're
necessarily racist or anything like that
but they have you know concerns that are
not being addressed or you know they
want an alternative to the part of all
the other parties that are all exactly
the same and when I went out there is
interesting you know I asked I'd try not
to put ideas into anyone's heads so I
just asked people what they were there
for and it wasn't even that nobody even
mentioned immigration right so it's not
even like I I agree it's not racist to
discuss immigration or even you know
want immigration controls I take a
different view but I don't think it's
racist they didn't even mention it so I
don't really see where this far-right
idea comes from other than as a kind of
slur to dismiss these people as you know
irrelevant and people that don't need to
be listened to it has become a bit of a
slow and it's interesting in Francis and
I talk a lot about the working class on
the show as well I wrote an article well
I think you read and spectator about
yeah fireEye being used as a slurred
this will be a few weeks ago now and one
of the comments on it was far
is now labeled people used to describe
the working class and I thought that was
quite an interesting way of looking at
it because whenever you know if a member
of the elite he rebels against the
mainstream narrative it's handled one
way but if you have a large populist
uprising of people who don't agree with
the mainstream narrative they are
automatically far-right yeah I think now
I think that's absolutely accurate and I
think you know a good example of that
might be the football lads alliance in
Britain you know nobody really knew what
they're about but they were declared
far-right straight away you know what
were they against they were against
terrorism I mean I think we're all
against fairness you know they want they
want to make their voices heard because
they don't think the issues being taken
seriously but you know it's it's it's
very strange that to be opposed to
Islamists blowing children to bits in a
pop concert is a far-right position I
mean it's it's bizarre it's it's just I
think what it represents is the way the
the working-class I mean not only have
you know they lost out economically over
the last thirty years or whatever but
their status culturally has really been
diminished you know and I think this is
very true this is true of the g-load
zones is too true of the brexit ears
it's like these people are these people
are gamin they're scum they're
uneducated they don't understand the
world they don't understand how things
should be and I think that this slur
far-right just embodies the way that
these people are just not seen as
important or worth listening to
well if I'm dangerous about that is that
there are people who are far right of
course yeah and then you get those two
confusion suddenly no one knows what
far-right means anymore because we do
need the label of far-right for people
who are far-right yeah we have to be
able to go now these people believe in
white supremacy or killing Jews or
whatever and they're different but when
you start to label massive groups of
people yeah then that's a problem oh
yeah absolutely is a problem and the
problem is I think with the Sheila Jones
and we brakes it in this country is a
lot of it is what you said it's because
people don't feel that they're
represented nobody cares about them
and that the only way that they've got
in order to make their voices heard is
to literally go out on the streets make
themselves as visible as possible in
order to have their voices heard and
that's a really dangerous situation
politically to be in that's right and
it's true that you know across Europe
the mainstream parties have been getting
becoming more and more distant from the
from the public and in particular the
people they're supposed to represent so
this is a particular problem for the
left for the labor wealth it's emerging
as a problem for the Labour Party for
the center-left parties in Europe have
been absolutely massacred over the past
couple of years you know you see the
Socialist Party in France goes from
being in government to winning only you
know around ten percent or something in
the elections similar things happening
in in Greece with their center-left
party and Andy an attending the
Netherlands as well and and and it and
in the Netherlands and in Italy the
Democratic Party against or center-left
their right party completely massacred
in the polls and there is this enormous
distance between you know especially the
center-left parties in there and there
are now who are now sort of representing
a more middle class urban intelligentsia
rather than a kind of working-class base
and it's really interesting that they
almost they wish that they didn't have
to represent these working-class people
actually it's not it's not that they're
fretting about losing them particularly
maybe some people are but they they
almost feel morally tainted by having to
represent these horrible working-class
people who were far-right and hate
immigrants and homophobic whatever which
they're not of course and and you can
really see that actually it's really
clicked crystal-clear in America with
the Democrats and if you listen to
democratic pollsters there's this big
argument between them as to whether they
should even bother to represent the
white working-class and there are people
that say we don't need them to win we
should just focus on these people and
they're obviously other more sensible
people who say you know well we should
we should be better than anyway because
they're working hard people that's what
we're for by the way but they're
genuinely people
making arguments that are the
demographics are going to deliver us you
know election victory after election
victory anyway why do we need to bother
with these deplorable people and it's
like they don't want their votes it's
like if those people vote for them
they're evil and tainted it's completely
bizarre weird in this country as well
isn't it because Jeremy Corbyn that's
exactly the direction that labor has
gone under Corbin and Corbin is a trade
unit yeah well you know the labor has
become more middle the the acceleration
of you know labor becoming a bourgeois
party has happened faster under Corbin
and under Blair which is extraordinarily
extraordinary because you know they're
made the way that Corbin is is presented
in the media is like it's kind of an old
lefty you know that could you know I
think with the right policies with the
right attitudes could really have won
back a lot of you know the labor
heartland you know working-class people
in the north but they're just not
interested they're much more interested
in satisfying their kind of remainer
London I think one of the worst things
about Corbin is the fact that he's not
honest about who he is and that he's
probably it and everybody knows he's
progress was like hey I'm straight
everybody was like no I think he is the
yeah he has performed the biggest
betrayal in a way of the two party
leaders you know Teresa may was a
remainer still a remainer
still wants to deliver a remain but
Corbin has completely sold out his
principles you know and there are other
people in the top cordon team who are
brexit ears too
you know they come from the Tony Benn
School of Euro skepticism which i think
is you know really that's kind of my
view on it you know where you'd rather
have a bad Parliament and a good king
you know his view was that we only lend
politicians the vote and they shouldn't
give we let you know sorry we lend
politicians their power and for them to
give it up to someone else who's on
accounts poise is unacceptable so Corbin
kind of comes from that tradition but I
just don't think he's that interested in
it I think he just has I think just has
other priorities and
is quite happy to you know abandon that
particular principle yeah he's got a
crackdown on the Jews now but let's come
back to the Jilly Jones for a moment
yeah just because I thought what you
were gonna say let's come back to the
Jews everyday man the Julie Jean one of
the things that I think most people may
have seen on the news when it happened
was the reaction from the government yes
because those were some troubling images
that we were seeing this was genuine you
know physical force being used against
people who out there be essentially
protesting so tell us a little bit about
how the French government responded to
his people amassing in the streets of
Paris and other major cities and you
know speaking up for what what they were
concerned about
yeah well the response to the G later on
has been incredibly authoritarian and
you know the the numbers of police on
the streets on some weekends would
actually match the number of protesters
so you'd have eighty thousand protesters
add an eighty thousand police so one
policeman / protester and the police
have been on the whole incredibly
aggressive they have been you know they
have they've caused a number of injuries
they're firing teargas grenades they
have these weapons called flash balls
which are banned everywhere in Europe
apart from France and these are kind of
rubber bullets and they're supposed to
be fired you know almost below the waist
kind of thing just to they're supposed
to stun people but the police have been
firing them at people's heads and people
have been losing their eyes you know
scores of people have lost their eyes
and you know we'll never recover from
that people have been losing their hands
there's a there's a really good
journalist called David de fresney on
Twitter and he has been collating all
the all of the police aggressions that
he can verify and when I last checked it
was over 780 incidents of you know
police aggression that could be verified
and I mean this is extraordinary you
know if this were happening in some
dictatorship it would be roundly
condemned it wouldn't be off television
screens but because it's macron you know
who is well liked
by you know the British establishment by
the establishments in other countries
it's not really talked about it and and
it certainly you know I'm not aware of
the British government having issued any
kind of condemnation in a way that they
would if it were you know some far-flung
part of the world and it's not all it's
also important to recognize it's not
just the it's not just the physical
authoritarianism it's not just that
people are being beaten up in the
streets by police there has also been
crackdowns on social media there's new
laws against so-called fake news fake
news just means news that the government
doesn't like it's you know it's quite
interesting that within weeks of that
law coming out a fresh campaign by the
French government was banned by Twitter
as fake news so you know the subjective
nature of a news is is obviously there
for all to see
you know they've been on Twitter for
instance have been under pressure from
the government in banning certain
activists the government have also
raided the offices of a newspaper called
media Park it's a left-wing newspaper
one of the few to stand up for the Julie
Jean and they've been issued with a
court order to raid their offices to
basically retrieve the sources of all of
these journalists which is a you know a
big no-no in the supposedly free world
marine lepen could go to jail for
tweeting about Isis what did you say I'm
trying to think what did she say she she
tweeted some graphic images of Isis
beheadings to say look this is what Isis
RUP - she could go to jail for that and
she said you know we don't I don't like
I don't know marine lepen well but I
assume she wasn't like Yellin so let's
have more of this right now she was very
much against yeah yeah and you know
marine lepen
unpleasant politician but you know she
could go to jail John McDonough marathon
the leftist leader his officers have
been raided by the police so there is an
extreme authoritarianism you know coming
over France under the rule of Emmanuel
macron supposedly the liberal strong
and the person who we were promised was
going to stand up against populism and
authoritarianism and save Europe and
European values and I it makes me
incredibly sad to see what's what's
going on over there do you think this is
a death throes of the EU project in many
ways I think it's the I think it's the
last gasp of that kind of not
necessarily the EU project I mean the EU
or the the EU I think will carry on
but in certainly within nation-states
and with with in in in national politics
I think macron was the last hurrah you
know the technocratic third way of doing
politics whether populist s' in various
countries are going to outright win
elections is yet to be seen but about
one in three people one in four people
depending on each election are voting
for populist parties in Europe now and
it'll be interesting to see what happens
in the European elections coming up
because that could be a real bloodbath
well we'll see because by the time this
into it comes out they probably would
have happened okay so the blood may well
be flowing in as people are watching
this but it's I mean when you were
talking about the injuries and all that
stuff I didn't know anything about this
yeah to be honest with you I can't say I
followed it that closely yeah but it's
not like it was there in your face
either you know you know I'm saying if
you if you watch the news if you read
the news if you try and keep the rest of
all the stuff you don't come across all
this information and it what you're
describing sounds a lot more like Russia
than a Western European country to me I
mean it's two sides to it I mean one is
the indifference just people to don't or
not yeah in the media not particularly
interested but to is that there are you
know a lot of macron fanboys in the
British media including you know people
who talk about write about France I
won't name them but you know they're
there and they will say I think and they
will try out the lines that these people
are far-right that these people are all
violent they're all thugs and that
actually the police have never started
anything
it was really interesting and most
recently the government had to actually
admit that it lied about 1g later on
story so there was there's video footage
of a load of yellow vests running into a
hospital so the government says of
course
look at these violent vile horrible
people storming a hospital how low can
you get it turns out that other footage
shows that they were being chased into
the hospital by police and the
government actually had to admit that
yeah we got that you know that wasn't
true we accept that version of events
before we touch on or and we're going to
talk about Internet censorship how much
of this and I see it reflected in this
country as a comedian you go up and down
this country and you play you know up
north and wherever else in town and
country how much is this ad is a clash
between the metropolitan elites and the
people outside who essentially have been
left behind by globalization and it's a
backlash and they feel the elite don't
care about them and they're right
because they don't I think I think it's
exactly that I think I think that's you
know I think I think that you can draw
in outcome I'm nervous about drawing
parallels I wouldn't draw it as for
instance I wouldn't draw I think there's
a lot of similarity between the kind of
people who voted for brexit the kind of
people who vote for Trump the kind of
people are voting five-star in Italy the
kind of people who are you know marching
in the streets of Paris in their in
their yellow vests the outcomes are
obviously very different so you know the
comparisons the comparison is there
certainly and yes they are you know
these are the people who are ignored and
I don't really like the phrase left
behind for whatever reason is something
about it that because they're right
behind yeah yeah I think they were
pushed behind yeah you know I think
they've been deliberative quite
deliberately cut out from politics not
just you know we let you put we pause
there because we wanted you to say
something even more provocative so well
the point I guess you're making is that
it was much easier to have these
working-class voices that were
I'm concerned about immigration let's
say yeah rather than have the debate
about immigration you just gone on oh
you're all a bunch of racist and that's
much easier yeah and I think that the
liberal establishment have found this
fantastic way of preserving their
interests you know it's absolutely
genius because you only have to
criticize any aspect of the setup and
immediately you're derided as far-right
racist whatever you know it's it the
g-loads honors permanent an example of
that you know it's nothing to do with
immigration but it has to be about
immigration in order to you know silence
it I guess if you are if you criticize
the European Union you know this is a
classic example you're a racist but
European Union is in my view quite a
racist construct the fact is that if you
if you look at the external borders of
Europe there you know some of the
strongest in the world some of the you
know the longest offenses and things
like that it's much worse than Trump's
war what what is happening in Europe
thousands and thousands of people have
died trying to get into Europe because
the border is so militarized there in
North Africa they are basically the
European Union is paying militia to put
people in camps or to basically round
them up and some people are being sold
into slavery that seems pretty racist to
me but if you do that and you support
the European Union you're you're immune
from the charge of racism whereas a
working-class person who's concerned
about immigration is a racist or Nigel
Faraj puts up a poster with a load of
refugees on it that's racist and that
needs to be outright condemned but if
they you know but if you either support
or preside over one of the most brutal
borders in the entire world
well you're not racist because you're
you're supporting this wonderful project
so it's there's an entirely selective
use of yeah of words like racist and
far-right and I think it's to the
benefit of of basically yet the liberal
elites they they've they've created a
moral force shields
for their ideas and for their way of
life and for their setup but reading
that article you wrote in spite I what
actually I found quite affecting was you
talking about the poverty the g-load
yawns living and then how much money
makan spent at this time I think in
order to refurbish his offices that was
what everyone was annoyed that the week
one of the weeks that I went everywhere
everyone was saying you know macaron had
spent yet hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of euros refitting his carpets
and it you know it played it played it
this image of macron which i think is
quite real of him is a kind of almost
monarchical figure they call him the
president for the rich which I think
it's quite true but he he doesn't help
himself because he has this haughty
attitude and you don't you know he
thinks that he deserves to be able to
refit his carpet for hundreds of
thousands of euros at the taxpayers
expense he thinks that you know he
basically wants to transform France into
a kind of nation of startups where you
know we're all just sitting in Paris
with on our laptops and I mean it has no
connection to real people's lives he's
very rude to poor people you know he
can't even have a normal conversation
with an ordinary person he you know he
slagged off a bunch of factory workers
as illiterate he he was talking to a
young unemployed farmer and just says
well I can get you a job why don't you
just walk down the street he once
describes people they left behind so to
speak as people who are nothing and that
was when he was trying to be nice about
them so it's good to see some of the
geodes on saying you know with and
noting people sounds like the russian
former president now Prime Minister
Dmitry Medvedev who went to Crimea and
he was surrounded by all these old
ladies and then we're all saying look we
have no money can you raise our pension
yeah and he went sorry there's no money
left and got in there was pensioners you
know pensioners just failing micron and
he's like well I don't understand what
you're complaining about
they have you know their pensions are
nothing it's like the people are living
on
pensioners especially living on you know
a few hundred euros a month and you're
saying well what do want me to do about
it you touched on earlier about the fact
that you know fake news and Internet
censorship and before I think there's
been a little bit of a sea change now
and that more and more people are seeing
the way certain posts get censored how
big is that this is a problem at the
moment and is it going to get worse do
you think I think it's a massive problem
at the moment I mean we've already seen
Facebook in the week that we're
recording this or maybe the week maybe
week before have banned a number a
number of people who have they've called
dangerous individuals people like Paul
Joseph Watson Louis Farrakhan the
preacher and who else I mean Alex Jones
is already banned that now you can't
even you can't even praise Alex Jones
who could find him dangerous if you
could find a man that rants about you
know water turning the frogs gay you say
that man is dangerous
I think it's funny yeah so there's that
I mean Twitter's banned a number of
people from Tommy Robinson to Karl
Benjamin and all these and you might say
oh we don't like these people whatever
who cares but what I find really
worrying is that these you know mega
companies in Silicon Valley and now now
seem to have taken on the role of the
censor and they can now decide what is
acceptable speech and what is
unacceptable speech and they have
absolutely no accountability to us you
know we can you know put pressure on
them I guess we can write lots of tweets
about it until you get banned until you
get banned
yeah I find that really to stow pian and
and what what is most bizarre is that
actually people have been arguing for
this to happen for a very long time you
know lots of people from across the
political spectrum have said the problem
with Facebook and Twitter is that
there's so much fake news there's so
many you know
too many Russian trolls there's too many
too much racism yep very much too much
hate speech yeah and what are they going
to do about it
and now they're doing something about it
and it actually is incredibly dystopian
and scary and it's gonna get worse
because the government's going to get
involved too and Britain has set out a
white paper called the it's called the
online harms white paper and basically
it's setting out proposals to have some
of the most highly regulated Internet
access in the so-called free world
actually it's probably even worse than
China because at least in China you can
go on a VPN and you can access what you
like don't tell the Chinese authorities
like I told you that but in Britain they
want to have the power to you know find
websites if they don't remove posts and
even take down some websites entirely
and you know I can I can sympathize with
people who say oh well you know who
cares who cares if Facebook gets a big
fine who cares Twitter gets big fine
they're just you know big tech whatever
it's been posed as this war on big tech
but really you know it's a war on us
because you know social media it's not
Mark Zuckerberg mouthing off it's it's
me and you and people we know and you
know your friends and family who are who
are you you know he occupies social
media and who use it to to speak their
mind so it's always a war on the user at
the end of the day [ __ ] rolls downhill
right they crack down on Zuckerberg he's
gonna crack down on us yeah he's gonna
have to try and protect himself against
the consequences of phrasing saying the
wrong thing on Facebook exactly so so
what it's going to do is it will make
those platforms more censorious because
they'll want to avoid getting fined and
now they've they've tried similar things
in in other countries so Germany has a
law called the net stay gay which is
which is the first and and it's you know
an anti hate speech kind of law and it
could find companies you know tens of
thousands potentially hundreds of
thousands of euros if they host hate
speech and so it just the
the effect that it has had is that
Facebook is now just taking down posts
left right and center trying to cover
its ass and one really funny outcome
shouldn't laugh but you know maybe maybe
we can take some joy in this is that the
minister who came up with the law and
who was promoting the law had one of his
tweets taken down yeah because they
didn't want to get fine he'd called an
opponent an idiot this was deemed to be
hate speech it was taken down right okay
so I agree with what you say I'm gonna
put forward the counter-argument yeah
which is which we look at the
Christchurch massacre yes obviously
awful there's allegations and I think
it's widely accepted that he was you
know radicalized online with certain you
know numbers of far-right websites and
all the rest of it and 4chan I think was
involved as well surely to people not
but you need to be protected from these
types of hateful far-right groups
especially vulnerable young people well
if these groups are out there I want to
know about them and I want to know how
we can counter them and actually it's
better potentially if they're on
Facebook and Twitter where other people
are than if they're shunted off to 4chan
where no normal people on you know these
kind of well maybe but you know if it's
funny it's like when a lot of the people
were banned from Twitter and Facebook
they started moving to gab and which is
like this kind of free speech social
network but if you go on gab it's only
these people yeah you know so it's full
of you know it's not I mean it's not
entirely just hate speech or
anti-semitism or whatever but there's
there's quite a lot of it but there's no
there's a lot of us around that could
ever challenge it you know it's so it
just happens on the ground and and that
makes the problem worse inevitably
that's what I did I went on gab I
checked it out and after like 10 minutes
I was like no no I don't want to be here
yeah left because yeah it is full of
race genuine racism and yeah and all
people saying the most horrible [ __ ]
that they can think of and like you say
no one is there to challenge them but
let's explore another counter-argument
which comes up a lot yeah chiz
we love freedom don't we
Fraser yeah don't you Francis I love
freedom don't I these are companies
private companies pursuing the free will
to have people on the platform that they
want you know if you ran a shop well
actually if you ran a shop you it would
be for us to do things but I mean their
company's doing what they are free to do
with their own subscriber base what's
your issue with that god this is the
dreaded libertarian argument I can't
stand these people I have a lot of I
have a lot of libertarian leanings but
I'm getting increasingly irritated by
quote-unquote libertarians these days no
I think I think that there is a point at
which Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
or whatever and that point is now that
they get so large that they are the new
public square in a sense you know you
cannot get by in politics a lot of
businesses you can't really have a
normal social life sometimes if you are
not on one of these platforms and so to
deny someone the you know platform to be
on there if you it's like you're casting
them out of public life entirely these
days so I don't think that you know I
don't really care I don't care about the
property rights of Mark Zuckerberg
anyway but even if you were concerned
about that I think the it's as much
bigger you know the problem for public
debate is a much bigger issue so what
you're then saying inevitably is we need
regulation of the Internet
no I'm not saying that either so that's
an interesting but I think that because
I know that you know when we have
regulation it's not going to be in a
free speech direction and it's never
going to happen the government's are
only interested in regulating to clamp
down on free speech and I simply cannot
see you know there's no way that you
could have like a you couldn't really
have an Internet First Amendment or
anything like that I don't think it
would work but I think it's up to us to
really you know put pressure on these
these companies to say that there is an
alternate view to the Twitter mob who
just wants everyone to be shut down to
say that you know we we value all voices
even ones we hate because we believe in
free speech and to say you know and and
for that to be a kind of competing
idea I think touching on what you're
saying I think the problem is is the
illiberal nosov de sort of the liberal
elite who we talk about and you see in
canceled culture yeah and we saw in
particularly the case of Michael Jackson
of course there were all those
allegations that came out about him and
all the rest of it and people were up in
arms and and then they were saying right
we need to cancel it we need to get rid
of Jackson we need to everything and it
was just you know how if you don't want
to listen to Michael Jackson's music
that is entirely up to you
but how dare you say to every other
person you are not allowed to listen to
it and I am going to be the moral
arbiter of whether you have the choice
or not well let's think I mean we have
these self-appointed you know moral
arbiters these kind of things it's like
new the new Mary Whitehouse is in a way
it's it's the book-burning mentality
essentially it's it's the it's the idea
that we're all so stupid and vile that
you know not only do I not have to
listen to this because it will upset my
mental health I couldn't care less if
people think that whatever do or
anything don't listen to it but it's
that other people need to be shielded
from it because they will you know
either it will hurt their feelings or it
will you know give them bad ideas and
and that everyone else is unthinking
unable to challenge the things that they
see and read unable to do anything other
than simply absorb and agree with it and
you know become this intimate troll over
time because there's so much there's so
much hate out there and we're all going
to just turn into walking peppers and
frogs if you're unless unless this stuff
is banned and we put a stop to it right
now and the danger is that we're
actually we you know we lose our ability
to argue and that's what I'm quite
worried about I'm not confident that a
18 year old now today could make
actually a coherent argument against
racism because they never have to do it
never heard one right it's just ban ban
ban and that you know that it that is
what is making us it's going to make us
stupid in the long term it's gonna make
us unable to respond to much more
serious political challenges because in
the end you know
we can't just pull the plug on if you
know ever if a far-right movement were
to emerge we're not just to be able to
pull the plug on it it doesn't work like
that you can't just ban it into
existence
I mean my favorite analogy I guess is
hate to make Nazi analogies but it is
true that there were laws against hate
speech in via Germany these people
atisha pne's were constantly getting
banned no banned for their views on X
why is that it didn't stop it it didn't
help in fact it made it worse because
they were able to pose as defenders of
the truth you know think about Tommy
Robinson right hid the fact that he is
persecuted by the British date which
which he is not a fan of his but I think
that's true gives him more credence
because it says you know these are the
things I'm saying what they don't want
you to hear and you know therefore I'm
the person telling the truth and they
are the liars so you know we have to be
really really careful with the
censorship censorship is more dangerous
than free speech I always take it back
to about six or seven years ago maybe
eight years ago when they heard Nick
Griffin on question time yeah
and he was just destroyed it's fantastic
moment yeah it was destroyed and any
chance of him being a credible political
force evaporated because if you were
sound mind you just looked at me when oh
you're clueless and out of your depth
yeah and ya know and and and you need to
bit you need to be able to expose
wrongness in order to tackle it you know
you can't just assert that something is
is bad and you know shunt it away then
the Nick Griffin episode is is you know
it's exactly that I think but I'm
curious about your pointer button on not
needing regulation and being worried
about it because obviously I understand
mistrust of government 100-yen on the
one hand on the other hand I think this
idea that you know trigonometry and
Spike and and you know a few other
people who care about free speech just
going to get together and put pressure
on Twitter and Facebook and Google well
we've got to make moussaka book on for
them yeah
how we're gonna get banned from
everything but I think this idea that
there's going to be enough of us putting
that pressure you I don't see that as a
credible way to deal with I mean look at
as you know I'm not a big fan of Donald
Trump I if you look at that leaked
Google a meeting video did you ever see
that was that they cut the kindly sent
someone or something like I don't
remember but basically the day after
they had a massive meeting after Trump's
election in 2016 and there were all in
tears crying and going on about how we
must never let this happen again
yeah right this has beat people at
Google because they think that they did
it yeah they think they think they're
like yeah no they they honestly think
that highly of themselves and they you
know created this monster or whatever
and it's nothing to do with them so I
don't put my point is I don't think that
people respond to incentives right I
don't think you and me and a few other
people complaining about the need for
free speech is ever going to be a strong
enough incentive for a huge tech company
to allow people the freedom to speak
which is why I think we will eventually
have to have some kind of First
Amendment for the internet right some
kind well I think I think what we need
is is a you know you're right a few of
us talking about it it's not going to
change change the world but what we need
is a broader cultural shift you know we
we the the problem is that culturally
free speech is not valued and there's no
reason why it couldn't be in in future I
mean the the thing you know the First
Amendment is a good example because you
know obviously there is a First
Amendment in America but it's not as if
you know you go on a college campus or
whatever and they have free speech far
from it right there is a real there's a
hostility to free speech among a lot of
young politically active people and you
know you can't tackle that through
through legal means that requires a
cultural change and you know it's gonna
be a hell of a lot of work it's not
gonna you know come easy at all well I'm
not sure I agree with you there because
we had Jeffrey Miller on the show who
you may know and he was talking about
free speech on campuses in America and
one of the things he was talking about
is actually Donald Trump he has put in
he's put in threats and he's made
threats that universe
these are colleges that don't uphold the
First Amendment principles will lose
funding and stuff like that so the law
if it's correctly calibrated can be used
to mandate freedom it can be used to do
that if you have a law for example that
says that you can't murder me for what I
say that allows me to speak freely in a
way that I otherwise might not I mean my
view is three speech crackdown is kind
of a contradiction in terms and it's
something we tried in in in Britain
actually I remember talking about it a
couple of years ago you know the
government put out this thing you know
we're gonna promote free speech on
campus it didn't go anywhere
it's not gonna change it's not gonna win
hearts and minds and it's not gonna it's
not going to stop people from thinking
you know the underlying ideas the
underlying ideas which are the problem
which are that today people think that
speech is violence or you know that
feelings at the end of the world the the
you know speech inevitably leads to
disaster at bad speech inevitably leads
to disastrous outcomes people also just
seem to think that speech can't be
counted with more speech so I think it's
a more fundamental battle than anything
that could be solved by the you know the
flick of the pen and what why do you
think this free speech and we talk about
it a lot and immediately it could get
the far-right slur comes up and then you
know they always joke about it we've you
know people makes knows about you know
trigonometry go are their right wing
they're obsessed with free speech why
why is wanting a freedom of speech right
wing because of your voice I don't think
there's anything right wing about it I
mean it's it's incredibly it's actually
a really radical idea you know the idea
that everyone should this should be
allowed to speak that should be
permitted to speak and should you know
should be trusted to listen to everyone
right I mean it's traditionally it has
been the right that has sought to clamp
down on free speech you know whether
that's through censorship of the theater
or you know we had Mary Whitehouse in
the 80s complaining about sex and all
that stuff it's only I suppose there's
always been since aureus how
to the left of course I mean we had to
Stalinism for Christ's sake it's not you
know but it's interesting that in the
60s in America you know you had a lot of
radicals and kind of hippie types who
are very Pro free speech and they
recognized that free speech was a tool
for them to affect social change and to
you know make the changes that they want
that there would be no civil rights
movement without free speech
there'd be no feminist movement without
free speech because there's Planet
[Laughter]
Russian so I'd come here help but I mean
it's it's it's it's so it's um it's a
recent shift I guess that I think it I
think at the moment I think you know to
be honest I think there are a lot of
people on the right who are maybe bad
faith defenders of free speech and you
know it's it's politically convenient at
the moment for them to defend free
speech because they are the ones being
censored in a different in a different
time maybe would it be the left standing
up for free speech because they're being
censored it's interesting I mean to talk
about the the one instance where I've
heard someone from the Labor Party in
the last few years talk about free
speech was in relation to the
anti-semitism scandal where they say but
why can't we say what we like about
Israel and you know Zionism and stuff
like that and you're right yeah why
shouldn't they say what they like they
wouldn't defend free speech in any other
circumstance so you know I there are
they're obvious the free speech is not
so much a left-right issue but I think
who supports it who's against it depends
very much on where we are you know in a
period of time and at the moment the you
know culturally the writer on the
backfoot
and so have to and so it's their speech
that's being suppressed and we need to
defend their free speech and that's what
happens is we seem to be in this world
now where we play this association game
all the time yeah it's like oh you
believe in free speech
who else believes as freeze-freeze eh
let's ignore the people in the middle
let's go to the far right oh you and
this guy believes and and it's always
about like who can you associate with
this particular view we're constantly
is like six degrees of white supremacy
like how do you connect this person that
because the right board came in six six
degrees of white supremacy but what I
particularly wanted to ask you about is
this culture of fear that has now
started which I've seen a lot and you
know I work in comedy with ultra-liberal
and then you do the classic over the
shoulder bah bah blah I was in last week
I was in a burger restaurant with my
girlfriend and chap sat down next to me
recognized me from trigonometry looked
over his shoulder and said thank you for
what you're doing and then went almost
whispered but you know you're gonna get
banned like everyone else and that we do
live in this culture of fear where we
worry about you know things being said
or misinterpreting and saying things
which are controversial in any shape or
form but worrying that there's going to
get overheard and people going to lose
jobs or careers or reputations are going
to get damaged yeah I thought I think
that's absolutely right and I think I
think that what is really interesting
what's been really interesting over the
last few years is that free speech did
seem a bit of them you know I've always
been a fan of free speech but it was
once a bit of an issue it's like what
people would say to me you know when I'm
actually a bit bored about talking about
college campuses now because it's like
no this is the real world now but when I
was talking but when I saw me about the
is ago people saying why do you care I
was like well because there are gonna be
real consequences if we let this happen
and now ordinary people you know who
have very normal average opinions
sometimes in the majority opinion feel
as if they cannot speak you know feel as
if they cannot speak their minds
normally and just say what they think
and that's really really scary and
that's really really troubling I was
doing some research for my Edinburgh
show which I'm doing about this also as
behavioural agreement form yeah contract
and last year in Russia because I want
to contrast what's happening in the UK
with what's happening in Russia four
hundred people were arrested for things
they said online yeah right do you know
how many people were arrested in this
country for things they said online nine
3300 yeah Wow and when I nine people per
day yeah when I tell people this they
they can't
there is not a single person that I've
said this to left liberal or a
right-wing Center whatever there's not a
single person who is not gone what the
[ __ ] yeah but people don't know this
right so I think a lot of people say to
you why do you care about free speech
because they don't really understand the
scale of what's happening yeah and and I
think it you know I think but I think
because because of the scale of it and
when you you know when you point these
things out to people I think people
realize that it is actually something
that affects you and you and me and your
mum you know your ground would
definitely first my mum yes because it's
not it's it honestly isn't just about
far-right agitates anymore it's about
completely normal opinion I mean you
know think about the way that people
might suppress their views on on brexit
which most people are in favor of think
about the way that people might express
might you know suppress their views on
the trans issue right most people in if
you look at polling don't think that men
can become women overnight they're not
bigots for thinking that they just think
that and you know but you can't express
that view because it's eight speech or
whatever you know perfectly you know
what is it isn't fraser hold on the
counter-argument might be well look
you're free to express your opinion
yeah breaks it yeah and the fact that
your neighbor might not like you and
throw dog poo over the garden wolf
doesn't mean that you're being censored
well I think you're very a a is possible
to be censored I mean there there it
says [ __ ] doesn't just come from you
know the state slamming its boot on your
face there are there are many ways that
people can be you know silenced whether
it's just through you know the through
fear through you know feeling that you
can't express a certain view there is
also you know low-level kind of
low-level policing of these things as
well with around hate incidents so
technically someone who has been
reported to the police for voting for
brexit and the police have recorded that
as a hate incident so it can happen
there's no consequences for that for you
legally but that's pretty scary right or
you know there was a guy who posted a a
limerick about transgenderism on hit on
Twitter and he gets a phone call from
the police they're not gonna arrest him
but that's still pretty scary you know
they find out where he works and you
know so there is a kind of creeping
authoritarianism that I think I think
that people should you know people are
right to be a bit wary of it right to be
afraid of whether people are being
censored directly is you know by the by
I guess but I at the point I've made to
people as well as look even if someone
got arrested and then didn't get
prosecuted yeah if you arrest three
thousand people a year yeah for saying
something and you don't then prosecute
them that is still the government
intimidating citizens into not doing
something because if you were to do
something and got arrested for it five
times yeah I never prosecuted you should
be worried about it yeah right will you
be worried yeah I mean it's it's you
know you could be arrested you could be
sacked you could be at the end of a
Twitter storm right it doesn't even
involve the government or your employer
but you you would feel so much it's you
know the pressure on you to shut up and
to stop saying what it is you're saying
or to recant for what you've said is so
great that it does you know amount to a
form of censorship we have we've got any
it's a question we always end on which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
talking about as a society bloody hell
that's the big one I haven't for one
yeah yeah have a second oh by the way I
realized we talked about brace it and we
rise to remain because we're good people
we needed to get it in there we always
do that we're gonna bring out a range of
t-shirts we votive remain with your feet
yeah because we're good people
yeah so we display our virtual wherever
we go that is the selling point of
remain isn't it yeah good person yeah no
that's it yeah that's that's what
they're for yeah I go I you know I went
to the romaine March and it's scary how
many good people there are the one thing
that people aren't talking about is I
think class and it's interesting that in
an age of identity where we are and and
of intersectionality I suppose the thing
with obsessed with dividing people into
these little boxes of
sexuality gender will even invent new
boxes for you know people whoo-hoo-hoo
fancy it but we we really ignore is is
class and I think it's really important
because it's not it's not just an
identity actually it wasn't identity I
don't care about it it's is about your
position in society and I think that you
know one thing that the kind of identity
politics of of the elite has really done
successfully is to mask those divisions
you know I think that's the real
dividing line and and they've managed to
almost paper over the cracks ever so
nicely and if you honest ly speak up
about these things then you're in
trouble because you're a bigot because
you're questioning you know you as I
said before you know they they have this
moral force field around around them and
you can't question them and yes so class
is the the one thing that I think that
people should be talking about be
thinking about a lot more and you know
it should inform how people see the
world
I've got France is gonna keep banging on
about his working classroom I've taught
in Croydon Bay what time am i setting
I'm saying I've got three seconds I'm
with ya I'm not I'm lower middle class
searching but there we go oh I see
banging on about class again yeah you
can't win all right raise thanks so much
for coming on it's been a brilliant into
the follow Fraser
on Twitter I remind us your Twitter
handle at Fraser Myers also as well
you've got a spite podcast if you want
to promote it yeah it's a it's called
the spike podcasts so and we do that
every Friday we talk about three
different you know exciting and spicy
topics and the knees so check it out
yeah check it out absolutely as always
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button to make sure you get
notified when a video comes out and as
Francis always likes to remind us a lot
people are getting randomly unsubscribed
from my channel so if that is you please
please please comment on the YouTube
video or send us a tweet if you're a
listener and will complain to YouTube
and they will do absolutely nothing
absolutely and I thought about doing
this as a social experiment we got a
brilliant clip we had was of Android or
talking about whoa comedy and it got it
refused to get promoted by Facebook
right and they would just say because it
contributed their Terms and Conditions
and I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
wanted to do let's see if we can try and
make that clip go viral so with our
family if you listen to two if you
listen to trigonometry or you watch it
you've got a Twitter account you've got
a Facebook tomorrow I'm going to put it
up we're going to tidy up some people
let's see if we can make it go viral
against those bastards best wishes
sounds great I was speaking of well
comedy yeah I'm doing sure Aaron Burr
Francis yes you are you are absolutely
yep you say something nice about it yeah
yeah it's gonna be correct but yeah
where is it and it's called oh well that
ends well it's about freedom of speech
and it's going to be a 7:00 p.m. and the
gilded balloon tickets are already on
their Danbury fringe website so grab
yourself a ticket yeah we'll see what
for I can get Francis to squeeze in a
joke okay right absolutely yeah it's
gonna need some no it's not go and watch
it but guys thank you so much and we'll
see you next week bye bye in a week
[Music]
there is the fall that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
a UNICEF on campus at SOAs right it was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti religion nante atheism
I think you're doing some quite
complicated mental arithmetic to offset
the bad people didn't think you're funny
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you just I mean you're
just so Bingham ever an outright you
know alright that we got there in the
end you did do the good thing by people
thematic needed right as I know going
each one of them is I haven't got any
racist sexist homophobic jokes I have
been a student at the University where
you can't make any joke about anything
he's Paul didn't want the students get
upset will trigger gets over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't like I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become men Gareth Bale right
went from talking them to round the
drink the guy left a perfectly good club
for more money everybody feels like
we're we're all kind of under arrest
we're all or everything we say can and
will be used against us in the court of
public opinion and can they're coming
for the comedian's first because we're
we're the ones that as you say are
allowed to transgress but everybody else
feels it and that's why the stories got
the resonance though it has
[Music]